let's talk about the number one mistake
that people make when they're drinking
water
now check this out these are some
interesting stats
the average amount of liquid consumed by
Americans if we average men and women
okay and this is based on cups but for
my friends in Europe including Dennis
one cup equals 236 grams okay all right
an average person consumes 4.3 cups of
just plain water
yet they drink a lot more fluids but
only a little more than four cups of
water that is definitely on the extreme
low side all right now the other things
they drink okay that's included in all
these liquids soft drinks okay 1.7 cups
coffee
one and a half cups
alcohol 1.1 cup tea a little less than
one cup 0.9 0.8 cups diet soda milk is a
half of a cup and then juice is slightly
less than a half of a cup 0.4 so as you
can see an average person consumes a lot
of liquid but not a lot of water now
let's take a look a little bit deeper
what happens when you consume things
that are caffeinated like the soft drink
like the coffee some teas diet sodas
possibly caffeine acts like a diuretic
so anything that's a diuretic is going
to create more dehydration it's going to
get rid of fluid anything with glucose
whether you're sweetening your alcoholic
beverage your coffee of course the soft
drinks and the juice also is a powerful
diuretic as well as that glucose tends
to lock up fluids as you drink them this
is why people that drink a lot of sweets
are retaining a lot of fluid because
this glucose is stored as glycogen with
a good amount of water so for every
molecule of glucose you store roughly
about three molecules of water locking
this water up making it unavailable to
you so anything with glucose anything
with sugar really is dehydrating to your
tissues now what about alcohol well what
happens after a night of drinking you
wake up you're completely dehydrated
you're very thirsty your brain actually
hurts because of the dehydration so
alcohol has a very potent diuretic
effect so the big mistake is that
thinking that you are hydrated because
you're drinking a lot of fluids and this
big push to get everyone to drink more
without really fixing the reason why
they might be dehydrated in the first
place is another big mistake because if
you're like the average American
consuming over 60 percent of your
calories being carbohydrate in the form
of refined carbohydrates you're
worsening your hydration you're creating
more dehydration now will it help maybe
it'll help a little bit but it doesn't
fix the underlying problem I mean this
is the big problem that I have with
medicine is that even if you bring up
the word cure right they basically
interpret cure as being you know
quackery non-scientific when you think
about it well cure is just resolving a
problem why can't we just cure something
medicine has become more about managing
the problem managing the symptoms but as
far as curing someone you're crossing
the line so this does relate to this
whole topic of dehydration because if
you really want to be hydrated you have
to look at all the different pictures
it's not just about drinking more water
let's just take for example your sodium
levels okay
sodium is needed to create hydration so
are other electrolytes like potassium
and magnesium and to be able to have
sodium hold fluid correctly you also
need a balance of potassium you need
this twice as much potassium as you have
sodium
and so the amount of sodium is not
nearly as important as these ratios so
it is important to have a good amount of
potassium and a good amount of sodium
but the ratio should be like two to one
and so if we take this idea that just
drink when you're thirsty that can be
confusing too as it relates to this
mineral sodium so let's say for example
you're a diabetic right and you're
thirsty well the problem with diabetics
is they're usually excessively thirsty
and they're peeing a lot they're trying
to compensate for the loss of fluid that
goes through your body because the more
glucose they have in their blood the
more they're going to pee and so if
you're diabetic and you keep drinking
all this water
you may neutralize the problem but
you're not going to ever correct
anything because the actual root cause
of the problem is never corrected and
that is just they're consuming too many
carbs now what about in the situation
where you're not thirsty okay but you're
craving salt well you really want to
understand what causes a salt craving
um it could be your adrenals are burnt
out okay the worse off your adrenals are
the more salt you're going to Crave it
could be you just worked out and you
sweat a lot and you lost a lot of salt
or it could be it's hot out or you have
a condition where you sweat a lot even
if you don't exercise and you lose all
the sodium or let's say you're on a
medication that you're taking diuretics
right and that's pulling all the salt
out and you're craving salt it's also
pulling potassium out too or let's say
you consume a lot of potassium in
electrolyte powder but you don't have
enough salt that can create an imbalance
too or let's say you're fasting and
you're not consuming anything and you're
drinking all this water for example yet
you're not taking enough salt with that
your body might then crave salt even if
you do keto for example the ketogenic
diet you tend to lose a lot of fluid and
with that you can lose your electrolytes
including potassium the more water you
drink the more salt you should crave
because drinking just a lot of plain
water will deplete your electrolytes to
a certain degree and so these people
that are forcing themselves to drink
like a gallon of water a day without any
salt develop a condition called
hyponatremia that is a condition where
you have a deficiency of sodium in your
blood and that's a very very dangerous
and so if we combine drinking a lot of
this water
with exercise okay and not taking the
sodium a person can be very very very
dehydrated because what hydrates someone
is not just water it's the balance of
these electrolytes that go in the cell
that help you retain the fluid in the
correct amount so to really correct the
problem of dehydration yes you need to
drink a good amount of fluids but you
also need a good amount of sea salt and
other electrolytes and I would say for
the average person
that does exercise to some degree should
be consuming between two to three liters
that's 8 to 12 cups on average of actual
water not these other things like coffee
and tea and alcohol and things like that
and I would especially recommend that if
someone is prone to kidney stones if
they're on the ketogenic diet just by
making sure that your urine is not
supersaturated
um you can prevent kidney stones even if
you're prone to kidney stones but with
that fluid okay to be hydrated you want
to add the sea salts maybe some other
electrolytes maybe in the water you add
some lemon apple cider vinegar but this
way you'll have both the volume of fluid
you'd need as well as the hydration you
need because for example if you're
drinking too much water or not enough
salt you end up with a deficiency of
volume of fluid in your blood and that
can create headaches that can create
fatigue that can create low blood
pressure that can create a situation
where you stand up and you feel dizzy so
these are just some additional points I
want to bring up relating to the topic
of water and if you haven't seen this
important video on water which has got
millions of views you might want to
check this one out next